when christopher columbus first arrived
in the americas he had no way of knowing
that he had set off a complex chain of
events that would lead to everything
from humanity's largest demographic
disaster to the founding of a new nation
nearly 300 years later to you watching a
video about the history of that nation
right at this very moment it's strange
right columbus's voyages to the new
world and those of the navigators and
settlers who came after him changed the
world to an extent rarely seen in human
history let's briefly review the effects
of these transatlantic voyages on europe
africa and the americas between 1492 and
1607 the period between first contact
and the establishment of the first
permanent english settlement in the
americas at jamestown so you might call
this the pre-british era of colonization
in the americas so what changes did
these voyages cause well there were
demographic changes and by demographic i
mean shifts in the structure of
populations the indigenous populations
of the americas faced a catastrophic
decline in numbers as a result of
diseases carried by europeans on the
flip side the populations of africa and
europe grew with the introduction of
nutritious foods found in the americas
like potatoes and corn contact also led
to the creation of new cultural groups
as indigenous people europeans and
africans mixed in the new world and had
children together the transatlantic
voyages also led to economic changes
including shifts in the systems of money
and labor spain extracted gold and
silver from the new world by force
compelling indigenous people and then
later enslaved africans to labor in
mines these riches flooded into europe
and caused a huge increase in prices
which may have led to the development of
banking and capitalism there and
european demand for laborers in new
world mines and plantations led to the
expansion of the slave trade resulting
in the forced migration of millions of
african people to the americas
columbus's discovery also fostered
political changes in europe and the new
world other european countries wanted to
claim colonies of their own and the
power structure among indigenous nations
changed too with the addition of
european allies and the destruction of
large portions of the population leading
to the downfall of powerful empires like
the aztecs the cultures of indigenous
people changed as europeans introduced
new material goods and animals into
their environment for example the
spanish brought horses to north america
changing the society of plains people
who could now hunt and follow herds of
bison on horseback and new religious
practices also emerged in the americas
as indigenous peoples combined their own
beliefs with those of catholicism
by examining the effects of
transatlantic voyages what we're really
doing is practicing the skill of
causation this is probably the most
important skill in the historian's
toolbox understanding and arguing about
what caused an event to happen or what
consequences an event had on society
later on now this seems pretty
straightforward for example a cause and
effect statement might be i slept
through my alarm this morning so i
missed the bus cause oversleeping effect
missed bus notice that the effect has to
happen after the cause missing the bus
didn't cause me to oversleep so until we
invent the time machine effects must
happen later than causes but there can
be a few pitfalls to watch out for when
we try to determine causes and effects
first not everything has just one cause
and one effect for example maybe i slept
through my alarm because i stayed up too
late last night watching tv that's
another cause for missing the bus and
there could be more than one effect of
sleeping through the alarm not just
missing the bus but also missing my test
in first period which was the most
important cause of missing the bus over
sleeping or watching too much tv and
which was the more important effect of
sleeping through my alarm missing the
bus or missing the test these kinds of
questions are what historians argue
about which was the most important cause
of atlantic exploration competition
between european countries or the desire
to convert new people to catholicism
another potential pitfall is one you
might have seen in a science class or in
statistics which is correlation does not
imply causation in other words two
events aren't necessarily related just
because they happen close together in
time or space for example although
epidemic diseases led to the deaths of
indigenous people in the new world at
the same time that the discovery of new
foodstuffs increased the population of
europe and africa the introduction of
diseases didn't cause those populations
to increase those were just two things
that happened simultaneously one way you
can check whether one event was caused
by an earlier one is to ask whether
event b
would have happened whether or not event
a happened the populations of europe and
africa would likely have increased with
the addition of those new foods even if
there hadn't been any epidemic diseases
at all the last thing that we want to
take into account while we're thinking
about causation is the difference
between short and long-term effects of
an event missing my first period test
might be a short-term effect of
over-sleeping but failing the class
because i missed tests would be a
long-term effect and maybe because i
failed that test i ended up focusing on
a different subject in school and
heading into a different career
that would be a really long-term effect
think about the effects of transatlantic
voyages that we've discussed and see if
you can categorize them into short-term
effects and long-term effects you might
find that some things fit into both
categories as processes that started
immediately but then went on for a long
time like the epidemic diseases that
immediately affected indigenous people
but then continued to reshape the
demographic composition of the americas
for hundreds of years
so let's recap what we've learned about
causation first historians argue about
causation as they try to pin down the
reason an event happened second causes
must happen before effects third a
single event might have more than one
cause or more than one effect and some
causes and effects may be more important
than others
fourth events that happen near to each
other in time or space aren't
necessarily related by a cause and
effect relationship coincidences happen
and lastly causes may have both short
and long-term effects immediate results
and downstream impacts that go far
beyond the time in question